so today i'm going to be interviewing my  co-workers on what their worst breakup  story is  so when i was in college i dated this  girl for a couple years  totally thought she was the one thought  we were going to get married and  everything  she ends up dumping me of course  you know a month goes by i end up  hooking up with this other girl  ex-girlfriend's best friend finds out  about it tells her so then one day i go  to class no big deal everything's normal  go to practice as i'm coming home  go upstairs say hi to my roommates i  open my door so this is what i see as  soon as i walk in  after practice my room is completely  trashed you know normally i'm a pretty  organized clean person  so this was pretty shocking i thought i  was robbed everything's totally chaotic  you know there's a condom nailed to my  wall there by the light switch  it's just completely torn apart